JOINING US NOW IS MICK MULVANEY,
FORMER ACTING CHIEF OF STAFF IN
THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE WHO
TESTIFIED BEFORE THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE YESTERDAY.
WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING WITH US.
IT IS NOT OFTEN WE GET SOMEONE
AT YOUR LEVEL WHO JUST APPEARED
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE.
SO IF YOU CAN, JUST DESCRIBE THE
PROCESS INSIDE THAT ROOM.
>> YEAH, THANKS, GOOD MORNING TO
BOTH OF YOU.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
IT WAS EXTRAORDINARILY
PROFESSIONAL, IF YOU'VE EVER
BEEN THROUGH A DEPOSITION, IT
WAS VERY SIMILAR TO THAT, A
DEPOSITION FROM THE CIVIL CASE.
FOUR OR FIVE LAWYERS FROM THE
COMMITTEE, LASTED ABOUT TWO AND
A HALF HOURS.
VERY WELL PREPARED LAWYERS, VERY
COURTEOUS, NO ANIMOSITY AT THE
TABLE.
THE ONE THING I GUESS THAT WAS
MISSING, JOHN, WAS THAT IF YOU
GO TO A DEPOSITION, THERE IS
GOING TO BE ANOTHER SIDE AND
THERE WAS NO OTHER SIDE.
THEY WERE ALL QUESTIONS BY THE
COMMITTEE, DESIGNED TO TRY AND
FIND OUT STUFF THAT MIGHT MAKE
PRESIDENT TRUMP LOOK BAD.
NO ONE THERE ASKING THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE QUESTIONS THAT MIGHT
MAKE PRESIDENT TRUMP LOOK GOOD,
BUT THAT'S FINE.
IT WAS NOT A FIGHT.
IT WAS A FREE-FLOWING DISCUSSION
OF INFORMATION THAT I THOUGHT
WAS HELPFUL.
I WOULD HAVE GIVEN THE EXACT
SAME ANSWERS OBVIOUSLY IF THERE
HAD BEEN FOLKS THERE FROM THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE SPECTRUM.
SO IT JUST REAFFIRMS IN MY MIND
THAT THE COMMITTEE IS
POLITICALLY BIASED, THERE IS NO
QUESTION ABOUT THAT, THE
STRUCTURE IS POLITICALLY BIASED,
BUT THE INFORMATION THAT YOU'RE
GETTING IS FROM REPUBLICANS LIKE
MYSELF WHO ARE TESTIFYING.
I WASN'T UNDER OATH, BUT YOU
STILL CAN'T LIE TO CONGRESS
ANYWAY.
THAT'S STILL A CRIME.
I THINK THE INFORMATION THAT
THEY'RE GETTING IS GOOD AND
SOUND INFORMATION.
>> DID THE MEMBERS, WERE THERE
ANY MEMBERS WHO ASKED YOU
QUESTIONS?
>> YEAH, A COUPLE.
THE LAWYERS WERE THERE IN
PERSON.
THERE WERE A COUPLE MEMBERS WHO
PARTICIPATED VIRTUALLY.
LIZ CHENEY WAS ONE OF THOSE.
SHE ASKED A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS.
COUPLE OTHER MEMBERS CAME AND
WENT DURING THE HEARING.
BUT THEY DIDN'T ASK ANY
QUESTIONS.
>> SO WHAT DID THEY WANT TO KNOW
FROM YOU SPECIFICALLY?
BECAUSE I SAID YOU WERE THE
FORMER ACTING CHIEF OF STAFF IN
THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE, BUT THAT
WAS WELL BEFORE JANUARY 6th.
AT THIS TIME, BETWEEN THE
ELECTION AND JANUARY 6th ITSELF
YOU WERE SPECIAL ENVOY FOR
NORTHERN IRELAND.
SO WHAT DO THEY WANT TO KNOW
FROM YOU?
>> THREE DIFFERENT THINGS.
SORT OF WHY DID I COMMUNICATE,
WHY DID I SAY WHAT I SAID.
I SENT SOME TWEETS AND TEXTS ON
JANUARY 6th, THEY WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THAT.
ALSO FAIRLY HEAVILY INVOLVED IN
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
I WAS THE HEAD OF CATHOLICS FOR
TRUMP IN 2020.
THEY WANTED TO KNOW ABOUT THE
DISCUSSIONS I HAD HAD LEADING UP
TO THE ELECTION DAY AND THE
DISCUSSIONS RIGHT AFTER THE
ELECTION DAY.
AND THEN INTERESTINGLY THERE WAS
SOME QUESTIONS TOWARD THE END
ABOUT GENERAL QUESTIONS ABOUT
HOW A WHITE HOUSE MIGHT RUN.
GRANTED EVERY WHITE HOUSE IS
DIFFERENT.
EVERY CHIEF OF STAFF IS
BUT THEY WANTED TO KNOW THE
PROCESS, FOR EXAMPLE, ON HOW
VISITORS COME SEE THE PRESIDENT
OR HOW WOULD A CHIEF OF STAFF
TYPICALLY TRY TO INCLUDE OR
EXCLUDE PEOPLE FROM MEETINGS
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
SO CLEARLY THEY'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT MORE ABOUT HOW IT IS
THAT PERHAPS RUDY GIULIANI OR
SYDNEY POWELL GOT ACCESS TO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
THAT THEY DID, HOW FOLKS LIKE
MIKE LINDILL HAD ACCESS, THE
INNER CIRCLE OF PEOPLE THAT
OTHERS DESCRIBE AS THE CRAZIES,
HOW DID THEY GET THE ACCESS THEY
DID WHEN THEY DID.
>> YOU WOULD BE SOMEBODY WHO CAN
TALK ABOUT PROCESSES.
THEY SPECIFICALLY WANTED TO ASK
YOU ABOUT A TEXT YOU HAD SENT IN
THE WEEK AFTER ELECTION DAY TO
CAMPAIGN OFFICIALS.
OH, AND RNC CHAIR RONNA
McDANIEL.
YOU SAID, I'LL GETTING THE
SINKING FEELING THAT EVERYONE
OTHER THAN ME THINKS WE LOST
THIS ELECTION.
I'M OUT THERE TELLING EVERYONE
WE HAVEN'T.
IF PEOPLE KNOW SOMETHING I DO
NOT, I WOULD APPRECIATE IT IF
YOU WOULD LET ME KNOW.
IT IS BETTER FOR ME NOT TO DO TV
AND KEEP MY MOUTH SHUT THAN TO
DO TV AND SAY WE HAVE A CHANCE
WHEN PEOPLE IN THE KNOW KNOW
THAT WE DO NOT.
>> YEAH, THAT WAS VERY
INTERESTING.
THEY DID NOT GET THAT FROM ME,
WHICH MEANS THEY GOT IT FROM
SOMEONE ELSE FROM WHOM I SENT
IT, RONNA McDANIEL, JARED
KUSHNER.
BUT IT WAS NOT ME.
IT WAS THE DAYS AFTER THE
ELECTION, I WAS SPENDING A GOOD
BIT OF TIME WATCHING THE RACE IN
ARIZONA.
AND I REMEMBER BEING ON A PHONE
CALL WHEN RONNA McDANIEL MADE A
THROWAWAY LINE THERE WAS NO WAY
WE COULD WIN ARIZONA.
I WAS SITTING THERE DOING
TELEVISION ON SOCIAL MEDIA
TALKING ABOUT HOW I THOUGHT WE A
GOOD CHANCE IN ARIZONA.
THE ELECTION HAD NOT BEEN
FINALIZED OR CERTIFIED.
SO I WAS A LITTLE SURPRISED THAT
I'M SITTING THERE DEFENDING THE
PRESIDENT, AND SAYING WE HAD A
CHANCE IN ARIZONA AND FOLKS
INSIDE THE CAMPAIGN AND INSIDE
THE RNC WHO HAD APPARENTLY
DECIDED THERE WAS NO WAY WE
COULD WIN ARIZONA.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS -- ONE OF THE
TIMES I FELT LIKE I HAD BEEN
MISLED BY THE CAMPAIGN AND THE
COMMITTEE WANTED TO TALK ABOUT
THAT A GOOD BIT.
>> THAT'S INTERESTING.
I HAVEN'T SEEN THAT TEXT MESSAGE
EITHER.
THEY SHOWED YOU IN THE CONTEXT
OF YOU KNOW -- AFTER YOU SENT
THAT TEXT, YOU NO LONGER
BELIEVED THAT TRUMP HAD A CHANCE
TO WIN IN ARIZONA.
THOSE OTHER PEOPLE THERE
CONVINCED YOU, NO, THIS ISN'T
GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> THEY ASKED ME THAT QUESTION,
WHEN DID YOU DECIDE THE
PRESIDENT HAD LOST THE ELECTION
AND I GAVE THE ANSWER THAT I
THINK A LOT OF REPUBLICANS GAVE,
WHICH IS THAT I DON'T REMEMBER
COMING TO A SPECIFIC TIME WHEN I
THOUGHT IT IS OVER, BUT
CERTAINLY BY THE TIME I GOT THAT
TEXT, I WAS STARTING TO WONDER
ABOUT THE INFORMATION THAT THE
CAMPAIGN WAS GIVING, NOT ONLY TO
ME, BUT TO THE PUBLIC.
>> ALL RIGHT.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT A MAJOR
DEVELOPMENT OVERNIGHT.
CNN, IT WAS A CNN EXCLUSIVE.
WE WERE THE FIRST TO REPORT THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, THE
FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS ARE
BUILDING A CASE THAT WOULD
BASICALLY GET AROUND EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE AND FORCE TRUMP
ADVISERS FROM THE TRUMP WHITE
HOUSE TO TESTIFY.
THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE IT TO
COURT, IF THE FORMER PRESIDENT
CLAIMS EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE,
THEY'RE PREPARING TO TAKE IT TO
CONTRACT AND SAY IT DOES NOT
APPLY HERE.
I WANT TO GET YOUR OPINIONS ON
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE WRIT LARGE
IN A SECOND.
FIRST, THOUGH, WHAT DO YOU THINK
THIS TELLS US ABOUT WHERE THE
FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS ARE IN
THEIR PROBE?
>> YOU PUT THIS TOGETHER, JOHN,
WITH THE INFORMATION THAT WE
LEARNED OVER THE WEEKEND, THAT
MARC SHORT AND THE
PRESIDENT'S -- MARC SHORT WAS
THE VICE PRESIDENT'S CHIEF OF
STAFF, AND ALSO THE VICE
PRESIDENT'S CHIEF LEGAL COUNSEL
HAD BEEN SUBPOENAED TO TESTIFY
AND DID TESTIFY TO A FEDERAL
CRIMINAL GRAND JURY HERE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C. ON FRIDAY.
PUT THAT TOGETHER WITH THE
INFORMATION THAT YOU JUST
DISCOVERED AND WHAT YOU'RE SORT
OF SEEING IS EVIDENCE, INDIRECT
EVIDENCE THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE INVESTIGATION INTO
JANUARY 6th, WHICH WE KNOW IS
GOING ON BECAUSE THEY CHARGED
OVER 800 PEOPLE, I THINK, WITH
CRIMES RELATED TO THE ATTACK ON
THE CAPITOL, BUT THE FACT THAT
MARC SHORT WAS THERE, THE LAWYER
WAS THERE, NOW THIS INFORMATION
THAT YOU PRESENTED IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF HOURS GIVES SOME
EVIDENCE THAT THE DOJ
INVESTIGATION IS NOW MOVING
CLOSER AND CLOSER TO THE WHITE
HOUSE.
STARTING TO TALK TO PEOPLE
INSIDE THE TRUMP ORBIT AS
OPPOSED TO JUST THE RIOTERS
THEMSELVES, THE PROUD BOYS AND
OATH KEEPERS.
I THINK THAT IS PROBABLY THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT PIECE OF
INFORMATION WE HAVE IN THE LAST
COUPLE DAYS REGARDING THE DOJ
INVESTIGATION.
>> IF FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS ARE
TAKING ON EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE,
WHO SHOULD BE WORRIED IN THE
TRUMP WHITE HOUSE?
>> NOT WORRIED.
NOBODY SHOULD BE WORRIED.
TELLING THE TRUTH IS FINE.
I THINK WHAT PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND ABOUT EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE IS IT DOESN'T ALLOW
YOU NOT TO TESTIFY.
I COULD HAVE INVOKED EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE YESTERDAY.
I COULD HAVE RELIED ON IT IF
THEY ASKED ME QUESTIONS THAT I
FELT OR MY LAWYER FELT WOULD
HAVE CROSSED THE LINE.
BUT IT DOESN'T MEAN I DON'T GET
TO SHOW UP.
YOU DON'T -- IF THEY ASK YOU THE
QUESTION IS TODAY FRIDAY, YOU
DON'T GET TO INVOKE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
THERE IS CERTAIN COMMUNICATIONS
THAT ARE PROTECTED.
THERE IS HISTORY IN OUR
JURISPRUDENCE OF HOW TO GET
THROUGH THAT, IT GOES ALL THE
WAY BACK TO WATERGATE.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
IT IS THE FACT THAT THE DOJ
SEEMS TO BE PREPARING THAT SORT
OF LINE OF REASONING TELLS YOU
THAT THEY WANT TO NOW TALK TO
PEOPLE WHO MIGHT BE IN A
POSITION TO INVOKE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE AND WANT TO PREVENT
THAT FROM HAPPENING.
AGAIN, I'M MORE INTERESTED IN
THE TRUTH.
THAT'S WHAT I THINK THIS SHOULD
ALL BE ABOUT.
I THINK IT IS WHAT IT IS ALL
ABOUT.
AND IF THERE IS FOLKS WHO HAVE
INFORMATION ABOUT JANUARY 6th
AND THE RUN-UP TO IT, THERE
SHOULD BE IN DIFFICULTY WITH
ANYBODY, NO ONE SHOULD BE
WORRIED ABOUT TELLING THE TRUTH.
>> IF THE INTEREST IS IN THE
TRUTH.
TO BE CLEAR, I THINK, TO BE
TECHNICAL HERE, IT IS ONLY IF
YOU BELIEVE THIS A FORMER
PRESIDENT OR PRESIDENT WHO CAN
INVOKE EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE, YOU
CAN REFER TO THE FACT THAT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT INVOKED
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE THERE, BUT
THAT'S A WAY NOT TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
ARE YOU SUGGESTING THAT YOU
WOULD PREFER EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
NOT BE AT PLAY HERE AND THEY
JUST ANSWER THE QUESTIONS?
>> WELL, KEEP IN MIND, IT IS
VERY INTERESTING, I LEARNED THIS
BECAUSE OF MY TESTIMONY
YESTERDAY THE PRIVILEGE ACTUALLY
RELIES -- LIES WITH THE CURRENT
EXECUTIVE.
THERE WAS THE COMMITTEE
PRESENTED ME WITH A LETTER FROM
THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE SAYING
THAT THEY WERE NOT GOING TO
INVOKE EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE ON MY
TESTIMONY.
WE COULD HAVE STILL PUSHED BACK.
MY LAWYER AND I HAD DECIDED IF
THE COMMITTEE ASKED US QUESTIONS
SPECIFICALLY THAT WE THOUGHT GOT
TOO CLOSE TO MY PRIVATE
COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE
PRESIDENT, WE WERE GOING TO
FIGHT THAT.
BUT IN THE EYES OF THE
COMMITTEE, WHICH I ASSUME HAS
SOME BASIS IN LAW, THE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE ACTUALLY LIES WITH THE
CURRENT EXECUTIVE AND NOT THE
PAST.
>> HAS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT,
HAS THE FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS
REACHED OUT TO YOU YET?
>> NO, AND I DON'T EXPECT THEY
WILL.
AS YOU MENTIONED IN THE OPENING,
I WAS LONG GONE FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE BY JANUARY 6th.
I WAS INVOLVED WITH THE CAMPAIGN
BUT NOT INVOLVED IN THE PLANNING
FOR THE RIOTS OR PLANNING FOR
THE RALLY ON THAT DAY OR THE
COMMUNICATIONS THAT WERE
INVOLVED WITH THAT.
>> LAST TIME WE SPOKE WE TALKED
ABOUT THE SECRET SERVICE TEXT
MESSAGES THAT APARENTALLY HAD
BEEN DELETED.
I'M PARAPHRASING HERE.
YOU BASICALLY SAID, YOU KNOW, IT
IS WEIRD, BUT NOT NECESSARILY
NEFARIOUS, IT RAISES QUESTIONS,
BUT IT ISN'T NECESSARILY
NEFARIOUS.
NOW "THE WASHINGTON POST"
REPORTS OVERNIGHT THAT THERE ARE
ALSO APPARENTLY SOME TEXT
MESSAGES FROM ACTING DEPUTY
SECRETARY OF HOMELAND SECURITY
KEN CUCCINELLI AND CHAD WOLF,
THEY HAVE TEXT MESSAGES THAT ARE
ALSO GONE.
HOW DOES THAT AFFECT YOUR VIEW
NOW OF THE SITUATION?
>> AGAIN, I'M ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE WHO IS SLOW TO JUDGMENT.
I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE FACTS
BEFORE I MAKE A FINAL DECISION.
TO YOUR ORIGINAL POINT, IT IS
WEIRD AND GETTING A LITTLE BIT
WEIRDER.
KEEP IN MIND, IT IS -- THERE IS
A GOOD CHANCE, I DON'T HAVE ANY
INFORMATION, I'M NOT TALKED TO
CHAD OR KEN ABOUT THIS.
BUT I KNOW THAT WHEN I WAS IN
THE WHITE HOUSE, I HAD TWO
PHONES, I HAD MY PERSONAL PHONE
AND I HAD A WORK PHONE.
AND WHEN I LEFT THE WHITE HOUSE,
I HAD TO LEAVE MY WORK PHONE
THERE.
SO IF THE SAME WAS TRUE WITH
KEN, THEN HE WOULD HAVE TO TURN
OVER THAT WORK PHONE TO SOMEBODY
ELSE AND HE WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
IN CONTROL OF IT SINCE HE LEFT
THE ADMINISTRATION.
SO, AGAIN, DOES IT LOOK WEIRD
FROM THE OUTSIDE?
DOES IT LOOK SOMEWHAT NEFARIOUS?
YES.
LOOK, THERE IS PLENTY OF TIME TO
GET THE RIGHT INFORMATION HERE
BEFORE WE JUMP TO -- WE MAKE ANY
FINAL DECISIONS ABOUT THIS.
THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT SORT OF INVESTIGATIONS
THAT WE'LL PROBABLY UNDERTAKE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C. IN MY LIFETIME,
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE TAKE THE
TIME TO DO IT PROPERLY.